how do they defend bam out of Bio
rolling off the screen
Butler with eight to shoot
Butler outside Martin back up top Butler
Butler a three-pointer off the side of
the Ring Brown the rebound
through the heat foul here I'm taking a
foul I'm not allowing them to get off a
three Denver does have a timeout but
they're not using it four seconds Murray
step back three-pointer slow goal fight
for the rebound Martin and it's over the
Miami Heat have tied the NBA Finals what
a comeback here on the road for the Heat
and it's one a piece
all right
[Applause]
once again the crit of the Miami Heat
Relentless and resilient
a three-point Victory despite of 41
Point outing from Nicola jokic but only
four assists big adjustment by Miami
[Applause]
[Music]
the matchup they want Jimmy Butler on
Joker one on one tough shot not able to
make it how did decision coach do you
foul or not they choose not to and
Murray gets a good look I like going
without a timeout they got into their
two-man game they switched it and then
good Separation by Murray just didn't
get it to fall
Miami Heat with 36 points in the fourth
quarter they shoot 11 of 16 from the
field I mean Butler played him well made
it a tough shot Murray also got a decent
look
[Music]
and Sam out of bile on the Miami Heat
with a great Road win here in game two